this is a fascinating development
medical office here in las vegas where
you can get a detailed
look inside your body before signs or
symptoms on the outside of something
serious as a heart attack or other
ailments to talk more about that we have
dr
john pierce with preventative diagnostic
center
dr pierce thanks for joining us today
well thanks for having me kendall yeah
this is unique technology
in the valley tell us what the scan
looks for
well basically we can scan from just
below the chin
all the way through the groin and in
doing so with the high
quality imaging that we're getting that
no other ct scanner
pretty much on the west coast can do
we're able to see abnormalities down to
about the size of a grain of rice
so we can look at the thyroid gland we
can look at the heart and the lungs
when we look at the heart we're looking
at the coronary arteries to see if
there's any calcium or plaque buildup
we can look at the liver the kidneys the
spleen all of the internal organs
in the abdomen we can look at the
prostate in a man the uterus and ovaries
in a woman
and kind of if there's any abnormalities
we can see them visually
like you said a long time a lot of times
a lot sooner
than any lab abnormalities or signs and
symptoms appear in a patient so
the idea is to be proactive we find
something we want our patients to be
proactive
and in the process of addressing those
issues yeah and when you hear from your
patients
it's fascinating we wanted to hear from
a recent contest winner his name was
daniel torres he won a full body scan
and was really glad he did here's what
he had to say
just come and get it done it's quick
painless and
i mean you figure stuff out you need to
show your doctor if you have concerns or
it's very very easy so dr pierce uh how
long does it take before someone gets
results
the results come pretty quickly i mean
the scan itself
takes about 20 seconds to a minute
you're in and out very quickly
so there's no claustrophobia or anything
like that once we have those
that the scan completed we send it to a
board certified radiologist
and he reads it and we generally get the
results within 24 hours
if there happens to be an abnormality of
concern
then i am the one who gives the call to
the patient because i want to be able to
explain it to them
i don't want people to get a piece of
paper with something they don't
understand and be
alarmed and get scared i want to explain
it to them before they ever get it
and and tell them the pathway to go
about so we can get things
start uh to be looked at a little
further if indeed that's the case yeah
peace of mind for sure and you
recommend people come in together do it
with a loved one right absolutely you
know a lot of times the things that we
find
you know like heart disease a lot of
times some of that stuff can be reversed
with diet and exercise if everybody in
the house is doing that together
it makes it much more easy to be a
successful in accomplishing your goals
love it dr pierce thanks so much for
joining us today really appreciate it
thank you preventative diagnostic center
is located at 6620 south tanea
suite 120 you can call them at that
phone number 702-534-70
900 you can also find them online at
pdcenterlv.com they have a special offer
heart scan with calcium score for just
125 bucks normally that's nearly 600
las vegas now will be right